what's going on
reject nation it's Craig Alba here so I
just got back from taking care of a few
personal matters got back here today saw
few requests for this trailer of Will
Smith starring vehicle directed by
Suicide Squad David Ayer for a Netflix
film called bright on the way back I was
actually listening to Will Smith's
interview on Conan
at comic-con he was selling me on the
movie said it's like training day meets
Lord of the Rings I'm going what the
hell that sounds awesome and I've been
monitoring the comments throughout the
day to see what people are requesting
that's dropping from Comic Con I did try
uploading a reaction is a Conan Wonder
Woman cold open video but YouTube
blocked it like right away it's not
visible she's good for I don't know who
to send a message to to get that
unblocked but I'll try anyway in the
meantime bright
why they're very Murphy area what the
hell
very lives don't matter today I'll take
a little LAPD style fuz oh and as you
keep doing are you gangster stuff I'm
just trying to sell my house don't worry
about that everybody's just trying to
get along and have a good life motor
races yeah well they're different
doesn't mean anybody's better or worse
than anybody
hey where's the diversity on I gotta do
it in my car I didn't ask for it but the
whole world is watching
it's okay you don't like me I'm not here
to be your friend how bad they all [ __ ]
pop off that you got nothing can hide
avoid gonna tell physical tells a good
face what my things were human needs a
lot more conical of heavy not making me
like that no no show us in route 23
those are really lightweight VRT Camry
[Music]
what a trippy film it was like a nuclear
weapon that grants wishes whatever you
want will be taller or shorter you want
10 million dollars they must feeling
that one
[Music]
Eliquis my Road
gonna kill you than me so now the stupa
shit's gonna start
imagine one situation
[Music]
we'll teach out of the Academy
no they do not yeah whoa radiance -
that's your answer - like Wilson in
actual like Cochran not in a prophecy
I'm going to stolen Toyota Corolla
a third Corolla bright the album coming
soon wow what a fascinating looking
movie Netflix man Netflix is original
movies holy crap I'm really looking
forward to seeing that movie or how much
this thing costs ninety million dollars
day Netflix is throwing down a kind of
surprise Will Smith agreed to do a
Netflix movie because I know it's really
about its big summer blockbuster I think
will have pitched it perfectly on Conan
training day meets Lord of the Rings it
has both of those elements I'm an LA
native I didn't necessarily go up around
like these kind of LA areas it seems to
be exploring a side of David Ayer I
would like him to explore more David
Ayer excels at those like la gritty
gangster cop dramas so you have all the
great David Ayer stuff there as well as
these fantasy elements that I hope stay
grounded in a certain way you know one
thing that I think a lot of people can
agree with with Suicide Squad despite
what you think of the entirety of the
film and I don't want to go into my own
personal opinion about it right now to
upset anyone but I do feel that a lot of
people think the finale of Suicide Squad
does get a little too big and carried
away and I hope he doesn't do that with
this specific film I know that he's
dealing with these fantasy elements I
still like the blend of a feeling
fantasy but also feeling like a reality
it looks funny to me it doesn't look
like a comedy but I feel like the
characters have a lot of humor in their
personalities Will Smith is doing you
know this Will Smith thing charming cop
in a dark life I like how this movie is
called bright I feel like so many movies
that have positive words in the title
are usually dark movies or sad kind of
films even The Pursuit of Happyness
story will v is a rather sad film and
it's almost like it'll be dealing with
themes of racism and segregation which
is a very relevant topic and I like Joel
Edgerton a lot as an actor I didn't
realize that was him it's kind of hard
to with all that makeup on but it's the
idea of the first orc cop that it is
fascinating sometimes we deal with these
fantastical elements I feel like it can
sometimes be even easier to get messages
about racism being wrong we deal with
fantasy characters being segregated in a
human world so in the makeup designs do
look a little bit like this
Suicide Squad makeup designs like the
Oracle fax look a little bit like a
Killer Croc type of character this is 90
million dollar movie maybe 50 million
dollars of it went to pain Will Smith
it's just a 30 minute trailer out of a
full length film I want to get this film
is close to a hundred million dollars to
put together however I feel like they're
probably going to reserve a lot for the
actual film when we do watch it because
one thing that appealed to me about the
visuals was it seemed to me that there
was a lot of it that was practical
effects while their CGI in it I really
was drawn to the practical side of the
effects to me that seems like it's a
probably a big collaborative effort from
Will Smith and David Ayer you do get
hints of a lot of David Ayer's
filmography and watch training day she
also get like bad boys and men in black
I really feel like all their elements
are strongest elements are coming
together here with the fantasy touch a
Will Smith has already dealt a lot with
science fiction but not so much
specifically fantasy this is this is
quite a ballsy film this looks like the
kind of film I would like to see in the
theaters but I actually appreciate that
it's on Netflix because I feel like it
can really be its own thing even more as
opposed to having it conform to whatever
major studios wants are putting out in
the theaters I think it can be something
a lot more original awesome and like
Netflix ooh right all right well what do
you guys think of the trailer decided to
see bright why is it go bright subscribe
to the reel rejects click that
notification bell check out our
exclusive personal rewards over at the
real rejects would love to have you be a
part of the community over there so what
are we some kind of bright people that
is worried